Gracias.
Creo que toda esta tarde ha sido increible para mi.
Siento como si fuera el Sutra de Vimalakirti,
un escrito antiguo de la India antigua,
en el cual el Buda aparece al principio y todo un grupo de gente
va a verlo desde la ciudad más grande de la zona, Vaisali,
llevando especies de parasoles con joyas como ofrenda.
De hecho, todos los jóvenes de la ciudad
-- los viejos no van porque están molestos con el Buda,
porque cuando fue a su ciudad él aceptó --
el siempre aceptaba la primera invitación que le hicieran, fuera de quien fuera,
y la geisha local, una especie de estrella de cine,
se les adelantó a los ancianos de la ciudad en un carruaje y lo invitó primero.
Así que el Buda estaba con la estrella de cine y por supuesto que ellos estaban quejándose:
"Se supone que él es un ser religioso y todo eso.
¿Qué está haciendo en casa de Amrapali con todos sus 500 monjes?"
y demás. Todos se estaban quejando así que lo boicotearon.
No quisieron ir a escucharlo.
Pero todos los jóvenes fueron.
Y llevaron consigo esa clase de parasoles con joyas que colocaron en el suelo.
Y en cuanto los habían colocado todos,
toda esta pila de parasoles con joyas que la gente solía usar en la India antigua,
El Buda hizo una clase de efecto especial que la convirtió en un planetario gigante
la maravilla del universo. Todos lo observaron y dentro vieron
la total interconexión de toda la vida, en todos los universos.
Y claro, en la cosmología budista hay millones y miles de millones de planetas
con vida humana en ellos,
y los seres iluminados pueden ver la vida en todos los otros planetas.
Así que cuando ellos miran hacia arriba y ven todas esas luces que ustedes mostraron
en el cielo, ellos no ven una especie de trozos de materia quemándose,
o rocas, o flamas o gases explotando.
De hecho ellos ven paisajes y seres humanos
y dioses, dragones, seres serpiente, diosas y cosas por el estilo.
Así que él hizo este efecto especial al principio
para que cada uno pensara en la interconexión
y en estar interconectados, y cómo todo en la vida estaba totalmente interconectado
Y luego Lelei -- conozco su otro nombre -- nos habló de la interconexión,
y de cómo todos estamos completamente interconectados aquí,
y de cómo nos hemos conocido entre nosotros. Y claro, en el universo budista
ya hemos hecho esto miles de millones de veces, en muchas muchas vidas pasadas.
Y no fui yo siempre quien dio la charla. Ustedes lo hicieron y nosotros los escuchamos a ustedes, así sucesivamente.
Y todos seguimos intentándolo, imagino que todos estamos tratando de convertirnos en TEDsters,
si es que ello es una forma moderna de iluminación.
Creo que sí. Porque de cierto modo, si un TEDster se relaciona con toda la interconexión
entre todas las computadoras y todo, ello crea una conciencia masiva,
en donde cada uno puede realmente saber todo
lo que está ocurriendo en cualquier parte del planeta.
Y por lo tanto ello se volverá intorelable --
La compasión existirá cuando ello se volverá intolerable para nosotros,
será completamente intolerable que estemos aquí sentados en confort y con placer, disfrutando
la vida de la mente, o lo que quiera que esto sea,
mientras que haya personas que están absolutamente plagadas de enfermedades,
que no pueden tener algo que comer y que no tienen un lugar,
o que estén siendo tratados brutalmente por alguien terrible y demás.
Simplemente se vuelve intolerable.
Si todos nosotros sabemos de todo, estamos casi obligados por la tecnología
a convertirnos en budas o algo así; a volvernos seres iluminados.
Y por supuesto, estaremos profundamente decepcionados cuando esto suceda.
Porque creemos que debido a que estamos cansados de lo que hacemos,
un poco cansados, por eso sufrimos.
Disfrutamos nuestra miseria en cierto sentido.
Nos distraemos de nuestra miseria corriendo a algún lado,
pero basicamente todos sufrimos esta miseria común,
de que estamos atrapados dentro de nuestra piel
y todos los demás están allá afuera.
Y ocasionalmente nos juntamos con otra persona que está atrapada en su piel,
y los dos nos disfrutamos mutuamente. Y cada uno trata de salir de la propia,
pero a la larga fracasa. Y claro, volvemos de nuevo a esta cosa.
Porque nuestra percepción egocéntrica -- una percepción errónea desde el punto de vista del Buda --
es que todo lo que somos es lo que está dentro de nuestra piel.
Y está adentro y afuera; uno mismo y el otro,
y lo que es el otro es todo muy diferente.
Y todos los que están aquí desafortunadamente tienen esa percepción habitual.
Un poquito, ¿no es cierto?
Ya saben, hay alguien sentado junto a ustedes -- eso está bien porque están en un teatro,
pero si estuvieran sentados en un parque y alguien se acercara y sentara así de cerca,
ustedes se espantarían.
¿Qué es lo que quiere de mí? Como, ¿quién es esa persona?
Así que no se sentarían así de cerca de otra persona
debido a la noción de que se trata de ustedes contra el universo -- eso es todo lo que el Buda descubrió.
Porque esa idea cósmica básica de que estamos todos solos, cada uno de nosotros
y todos los demás somos seres diferentes,
entonces ello nos coloca en una situación imposible, ¿no es así?
¿Quién será quien va a recibir atención suficiente del mundo?
¿Quién va a obtener lo suficiente del mundo?
¿Quién no va a ser superado por un número infinito de otros seres --
si tú eres diferente de todos los otros seres?
Así que la compasión viene cuando tú te das cuenta
sorpresivamente de que puedes perderte a tí mismo de una cierta manera:
mediante el arte, mediante la meditación, mediante el entendimiento, mediante el conocimiento de hecho,
sabiendo que no existe tal barrera,
sabiendo de tu interconexión con otros seres.
Puedes experimentarte a tí mismo como a los demás seres
cuando observas más allá de la ilusión de estar separado de ellos.
Cuando lo haces, te forzas a sentir lo que ellos sienten.
Afortunadamente, dicen -- yo todavía no estoy seguro --
pero afortunadamente, dicen que cuando llegas a ese punto, porque algunas personas han dicho
en la literatura budista: ¡Oh! ¿Quién quisiera ser realmente compasivo?
¡Qué terrible! Ya soy tan miserable por mi cuenta. La cabeza me duele.
Los huesos me duelen. Voy del nacimiento a la muerte. Nunca estoy satisfecho.
Nunca tengo suficiente, incluso siendo billonario nunca tengo suficiente.
Necesito cien mil millones, así que así soy.
Imaginen si yo tuviera que sentir siquiera el sufrimiento de otras cien personas.
Sería terrible.
Pero aparentemente, esta es una paradoja extraña de la vida.
Cuando ya no estás encerrado en tí mismo,
y mientras la sabiduría o la inteligencia, o el conocimiento científico
de la naturaleza del mundo, sea lo que permita a tu mente expandirse,
y sentir empatía aumentando la habilidad humana básica de sentirla,
y darse cuenta de que tú eres el otro,
de cierta manera a través de esa apertura, puedes ver la naturaleza más profunda de la vida, y puedes hacerlo,
salir de este terrible círculo de hierro del yo, mi, mi, mío,
como los Beatles solían cantarlo.
Saben, realmente aprendimos todo en los años 60.
Lástima que nadie jamás se despertó,
y han tratado de suprimirlo desde entonces.
Yo, mi, mi, mío. Esa canción es como la canción perfecta. Una enseñanza perfecta.
Pero cuando nos liberamos de aquello,
entonces de cierta manera nos interesamos en todos los otros seres.
Y nos sentimos nosotros mismos de una manera distinta. Es muy extraño.
Es totalmente extraño.
Al Dalai Lama siempre le gusta decir --
él dice que cuando uno da a luz en su mente a la idea de la compasión,
se debe a que comprendes que tú mismo, tus dolores y tus placeres,
son finalmente un teatro demasiado pequeño para tu inteligencia.
Es realmente muy aburrido sentirse así, de esa u otra manera. Ya saben --
y mientras más te enfocas en cómo te sientes, por cierto, se siente peor.
Por ejemplo, incluso cuando te la estás pasando bien,
¿cuándo se terminan los buenos momentos?
Los buenos momentos se terminan cuando piensas, ¿qué tan buenos son?
Y entonces nunca son lo suficientemente buenos.
Me encanta lo que Lelei dijo acerca de la forma de ayudar a quienes sufren intensamente
en el plano físico, o en otros planos; es pasándola bien,
ayudar pasándola bien.
Creo que el Dalai Lama debió escuchar eso. Desearía que hubiera estado aquí para escucharlo.
Él una vez me dijo -- se veía un tanto triste;
se preocupa mucho de la diferencia entre ricos y pobres.
Se veía un poco triste porque decía: bueno, hace cien años
aquellos vinieron y les quitaron todo a los ricos.
Ya saben, las grandes revoluciones comunistas, en Rusia, China y demás.
Tomaron todo a través del uso de la violencia,
diciendo que se lo darían a todos, y después quedaron mucho peor.
No ayudaron en lo absoluto.
¿Entonces qué podría cambiar este terrible abismo que se ha abierto hoy en el mundo?
Entonces él me mira.
Así que dije : "Bueno, usted sabe, usted está en todo ello. Usted lo enseña: es la generosidad."
Fue todo lo que pude pensar. ¿Qué es la virtud?
Pero claro, creo que la clave para salvar el mundo, la clave de la compasión,
es que sea mucho más divertido.
Debe hacerse con gusto. La generosidad es más divertida. Esa es la clave.
Todo mundo tiene la idea equivocada. Piensan que el Buda era muy aburrido,
y se sorprenden cuando conocen al Dalai Lama, quien es bastante alegre.
Incluso cuando su pueblo está siendo objeto de un genocidio --
y créanme, él siente cada golpe sobre la cabeza de cada monja anciana,
en cada prisión china. Él lo siente.
Él siente la manera en que están cazando a los yaks en la actualidad.
No diré siquiera cómo lo hacen. Pero él lo siente.
Y sin embargo, es muy alegre. Es extremadamente alegre.
Porque cuando te abres de esa manera,
entonces simplemente no puedes -- ¿de qué sirve añadir la miseria de uno mismo a la miseria de los otros?
Tienes que encontrar alguna visión done veas lo esperanzador que es,
cómo puede cambiarse.
Miren eso tan bello que Chiho nos mostró. Ella nos espantó con el hombre de lava.
Nos espantó con que venía el hombre de lava,
luego con que venía el tsunami,
pero finalmente hubo flores y árboles, y fue muy bello.
Es realmente encantador.
Así, la compasión significa sentir los sentimientos de los demás,
y de hecho, el ser humano es compasión.
El ser humano casi no tiene tiempo.
El ser humano es compasión porque, ¿para qué es nuestro cerebro?
Ahora, el cerebro de Jim está memorizando el almanaque.
Pero podría memorizar todas las necesidades de todos los seres que son él, que él será y que él fue.
Podría memorizar toda clase de cosas fantásticas para ayudar a muchos seres.
Y se divertiría mucho haciéndolo.
Así que la primera persona que se ponga feliz,
cuando uno deja de enfocarse en la situación egoísta de qué tan feliz soy yo,
cuando siempre estás insatisfecho --
como Mick Jagger nos dijo, nunca obtienes satisfacción de esa manera.
Así que entonces decides; bueno, estoy harto de mí mismo.
Voy a pensar en cómo hacer felices a otras personas.
Voy a levantarme por la mañana y pensaré,
¿qué es lo que puedo hacer por otra persona? Incluso por un perro, mi perro, mi gato,
mi mascota, mi mariposa.
Y la primera persona que se pone feliz cuando haces eso,
no haces nada para nadie más, pero tú te vuelves feliz, tú mismo,
porque toda tu percepción se amplía,
y de repente ves todo el mundo y a toda la gente en él.
Y te das cuenta de que esto -- estar con estas personas --
es el jardín de flores que Chiho nos mostró.
Es el Nirvana.
Y mi tiempo se acabó. Y conozco los mandamientos TED.
Gracias.